what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have major news about
Avengers Secret Wars and some pretty big
news about Deadpool 3 that we'll talk
about later as well but many of you
might have heard that Marvel Studios was
kind of switching things up internally
when it comes to the directors and the
writers of some shows they are also kind
of changing their strategy right now for
how they are releasing Disney plus
content they're scaling back releasing
fewer Disney Plus shows this has been
confirmed by both Marvel and Disney and
their goal basically moving forward is
to try and make each Disney Plus show
feel like a big event which is awesome
but what they've done recently was also
get rid of some of the writers and
directors that they've had for some
upcoming shows and movies a director for
Avengers Secret Wars has never been
announced we haven't had an official
director assigned to that movie yet
however we did have a writer Michael
Waldron he wrote Loki season 1 and he
helped write Multiverse of Madness as
well and was set to write Avengers
Secret Wars the same thing goes with
Jeff loveness he originally wrote
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania and was
going to be writing the script for
Avengers King Dynasty however we have
heard that both of them are no longer
attached to these projects and will not
be writing King Dynasty and Secret Wars
well today we have an update about who
might be writing these films and who
might be directing Avengers Secret Wars
now we have a director for Avengers King
Dynasty as far as we know right now
Dustin Daniel is still the
director for Kang Dynasty and he
directed Shang Chi and the legend of the
ten Rings which is one of the best films
not only in phase four but in the entire
Multiverse Saga so that's still good
news and let's break down what we've
heard recently about the writers and the
directors for these upcoming Avengers
films and dive into Deadpool 3 as well
so if you're new don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest news we're also giving
away an Xbox A PS5 to Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month all you gotta do
is subscribe and leave a comment on our
videos to enter so let's start off by
talking about possibly the biggest news
that we've heard in a while when it
comes to the Multiverse Saga and that is
the fact that we are hearing from
Insider Source my time to shine hello
that Sam raymie could be directing
Avengers Secret Wars in fact her direct
tweet today stated that sources
confirmed that Sam Raimi is Marvel's Top
Choice to direct Secret Wars now Sam
Raimi is a legend many people know who
he is if you don't he directed the very
first three Toby Maguire Spider-Man
films he's also famous for a ton of
other movies that he's done especially
in the horror genre and he was hesitant
to come back to Marvel Studios after all
of the hate that he got for Spider-Man 3
but he came back and he directed
Multiverse of Madness and he said that
he was absolutely ecstatic to come back
and he was so excited to see Tobey
Maguire go back and Spider-Man no way
home as well and side note I would love
for him to direct Secret Wars because
we've heard Tobey Maguire Spider-Man is
going to appear in secret Wars and I
would love to see the two of them get
back together again this time working
together in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because of course that did not
exist way back when those first
Spider-Man films came out although Sam
Raimi did include a doctor strange
reference in Spider-Man 2. now before
people go on and start talking about
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness a lot more people like that film
than a lot of people would have you
believe in fact for the People's Choice
Awards it actually won the best movie of
2022. so clearly a lot of people truly
did like this movie I'm not saying it's
not without its flaws however you have
to consider what the situation was
before Sam Raimi came in Scott
Derrickson who wrote and directed the
very first Doctor Strange movie was set
to write and direct the second one and
he already had a script done he really
wanted to make the first horror movie
for Marvel Studios but apparently he
wanted it to be over the top and a
little bit too much and Kevin feige said
we can't do this and Scott Derrickson
basically said well if I can't make this
movie that I want to make I don't really
want to make it they part ways and
that's when Sam came in with writer
Michael Waldron so they came into
something that was already made a script
for it was already done and they kind of
had to work with what they had and then
rewrite a script in a very short amount
of time plus of course Kevin feige has
things that you need to include in a
movie as well and I believe that they
did the best with the situation that
they were put in and I believe that it
would be a lot different with Secret
Wars because I believe that Sam Raimi
really does have the chops to direct an
amazing Secret Wars film especially
since he worked with Marvel Studios way
back then with the very first Spider-Man
films and now he's come back and worked
with Marvel Studios in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe plus not to mention
he's just a very talented and very well
respected director I think he would do
an incredible job but go ahead and let
us know your thoughts about this down
below would you like to see Sam Raimi
direct Avengers Secret Wars now we do
have news about the writers as well one
thing about having Michael Waldron and
Jeff lubnis write King Dynasty and
Secret Wars something that was really
cool is that one they are both extremely
good friends so you know they would work
closely together to make make sure
whatever happened in King Dynasty would
line up well with what happens in secret
Wars but two they both were writers for
Rick and Morty and the reason that this
was so cool is because one people love
that show but two a lot of Multiverse
stuff happens in that show they really
do explore the Multiverse a lot in Rick
and Morty and if you've seen it you know
what I'm talking about but basically
these two writers had a lot of
experience writing about a Multiverse
and I'm sure that's why Marvel Studios
hired them in the first place to write
these two films because these two films
won the King Dynasty is going to really
kick off a shattered Multiverse and two
secret Wars is going to be all about the
Multiverse perhaps the Multiverse
already being destroyed and them having
to restore it and incursions happening
in all of the universes combining
possibly into just one Universe in one
timeline so there is value there for
having writers who have really
experienced writing about a Multiverse
before and according to my time to shine
hello Kevin feige might be looking at
other Rick and Morty writers to direct
other MCU films for the Multiverse Saga
responding to a tweet about Michael
Waldron and Jeff loveness being taken
off King Dynasty in secret Wars my time
to shine hello stated this true but
pre-strikes he was in talks with other
Rick and Morty writers for other MCU
projects it's far from over so Kevin
feige was in talk with other Rick and
Morty writers to direct some other
projects for the MCU again in theory it
makes sense because they have experience
writing about the Multiverse and he
could be getting these writers to come
on for Avengers Secret Wars and Avengers
King Dynasty plus other films as well as
my time to shine hello States now it is
nice to get New Riders to come in and
get a fresh perspective however I would
personally love to see what Sam Raimi
himself could come up with if they want
him to direct Secret Wars that's
fantastic but I would personally love to
see what kind of script he would write
but we'll have to wait and see on that
in the meantime let us know what you
think about Rick and Morty writers
writing the next Avengers films you
think it would be good or do you think
they should get some other writers and
get a fresh perspective let us know down
below now one last report of the day is
about Deadpool 3. according to Daniel
rpk Deadpool 3 might feature battle
world now this kind of does make sense
based off of what we've heard about
Deadpool 3 and of course based off of
the fact that we are currently in the
Multiverse Saga and it's kind of
becoming a mess right now the kangs are
on the loose we've seen that they have
formed the Multiverse their own way but
we also know that people like Loki and
Deadpool and other characters are going
to be causing incursions we're looking
at you Doctor Strange so Secret Wars in
the comics and battle World particularly
was made by Dr Doom the Multiverse
collapses and Dr Doom creates a new
reality out of the remnants of destroyed
universes so basically a bunch of
incursions happen the Multiverse gets
destroyed and whatever is left of that
destroyed Multiverse Doctor Doom when he
gets the power of the beyonder uses all
of those remnants puts them together
forms a world forms a reality and calls
that battle world and doom would rule
battle world he would rule it with
Doctor Strange by his side he also had
the Thor chord working for him and the
world was split off into different
remains and some of these remains had
remnants of old universes still intact
he assigned a leader or a baron or
baroness to each territory and you could
not cross out of your territory you
could not leave the region and if you
did so the Thor core would show up and
let's just say would discipline you well
this could happen in Deadpool 3 in a
really creative way what we've heard so
far is that there's going to be a
universe that is ruled by the X-Men and
particularly Magneto so what we are
theorizing could happen in Deadpool 3 is
that in this universe where the X-Men
and Magneto rule instead of Dr Doom
having created battle World it could
actually be Magneto I think that this
would be a really cool idea because one
it would be a little bit of a Twist of
battle World Plus that means Avengers
Secret Wars would be a little bit
different than what we've known the
comics to be as well that way we don't
know what's going to happen but two we
don't have a little Cameo for Doctor
Doom unless it is the old Doctor Doom
Julian McMahon which it very well could
be because we have heard rumors that the
original Fantastic Four Jessica Alba
Chris Evans Etc could be returning for
this movie as well that would be cool I
would love for that to happen I just
don't want them to introduce the new MCU
Doctor Doom in this film I want him to
have a proper introduction not a quick
cameo in another film but if it's Julian
returning that would be absolutely epic
but we know that Magneto is going to be
in charge of one particular universe so
it sounds like that Universe could be
the remnants of other universes and
could be ruled by Magneto so this could
be a version of Secret Wars in Deadpool
3. I think it would be really cool but
go ahead and let us know your thoughts
about that in the comments down below
also let us know what you think about
the possible writers for Avengers King
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars and the
possibility of Sam Raimi returning to
direct Avengers Secret Wars leave your
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the MCU you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well if
you'd like to and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf